[Music]
noticed what imaginary Armando con
diversity feeding Tala I have a feeling
that the Italian version is probably
better and less preservative II tasting
the same tongue grandi seem especially
metallic element o de fondos cannot
remain typical plastic ax
this is adorable
it's just so adorable I love it no metal
enrolled at even omit the metal on you
tell em across visually these look
pretty much the same abdomen karate
picado erotica school color exactly the
same one of them smells more I'm
hazelnutty and I'm guessing that that's
the Italian one
Suzuka reporter just another
illegitimate if you for them popular
chisel my immediate reaction is that
this one's like a little nuttier and
this one's a little more chocolatey
quest essentially pure cacao is
essentially Manolo no column this one
sugar has more sugar in it which makes
me think it's the American one Luna can
different psychotropic a questa and
multiple - requested with a puke Ramona
I'm almost positive that this is the
Italian one because the milk tastes
different and it's less sugary and that
this is the American one Italy is doing
everything better than we are
questa equal italiana means requests
actual Americana
nandi Ptolemy's analysis confirms
bilateral monopoly Ipanema I think this
one's a time I think this won't America
quest ce que el italiano equesticle
americano makovica sadar Lacroix's
confer are completamente diversity
supporter I'm gonna say this one's
American this one in town this is like
the first time a non American version of
something was the sweeter version go to
a world market go to farmers market go
to a black market
I don't care get them to tell her that
you need in your life because this is so
different